he heard this awesome story of a man who
was there with his small daughter was
watching his daughter watched the show
and he was so relieved because he said
that it was the first time that she had
smiled since they left Syria
everybody laughs in the same language
something pretty isolated family this in
their own tents and just in their own
little groups and then all of a sudden
these clowns come and we have a parade
through cast all the tents and all the
children and adults just come and start
following us and then they all sit
together and watch the show together and
laugh together and clap together and by
the end of the show they're all on the
same team even if they're from different
countries they don't speak the same
language they're all together
you